so here now Republican congressman Matt
Gaetz a member of the Judiciary
Committee congressman good to have you
with us what do you what do you make of
that and what are these issues that are
outstanding that are too far afield in
this package for Republicans like
yourself I think we would all agree that
the coronavirus bill does not need any
poison pills and I think this is the
easy way to spot the issues everyone is
for testing everyone is for medical
infrastructure like ventilators where
Republicans have challenges where we've
got legislative provisions that forever
change entitlement programs we should
not use the coronavirus as an excuse to
go in dramatically expand eligibility in
the SNAP program for example so we want
solutions that are medical
infrastructure focused testing focused
but that don't rewrite entitlements
while we're dealing with the coronavirus
seems like it makes sense I mean
couldn't you put provisions on it that
it's for a specific period of time and
you know I think if most Americans get
wind of that they they would probably be
behind that unfortunately we see the
Speaker of the House trying to jam the
president putting in for example
Reformation 'z to abortion laws and
abortion practices the Hyde Amendment
for example into this legislative
package is a way to try to make
Republicans and the president look like
we don't support testing now the good
news is the president's national
emergency declaration has unlocked
tremendous potential for example here in
Florida as a result of that declaration
we spent six million dollars to buy
additional ventilators and put them
close to communities that were likely to
be impacted I don't think there's gonna
be a lot of patients in America for
things that are outside of the zone of
working on this immediate problem and
you know I think everybody would hope
that both sides would agree to that you
never the other things can be battled
over at another time in place with
regard to to you so you self quarantined
for how many days and and why and what
made you decide that it was okay to just
stop I held the phone of someone at CPAC
who had tested positive for coronavirus
I was notified of that 11 days after the
event as I was on Air Force One with the
president as soon as that Air Force one
ride was over I was put in a DoD vehicle
taken to Walter Reed tested that test
result came back negative health care
professional said I should still
maintain the 14 day quarantine that
ended at 2 p.m. yesterday so not exactly
straight out of Compton but I am
straight out of quarantine I mean you
know what do you think about the
president I was just a little surprised
today watching how everybody was you
know sort of standing so close together
and they're all on the same microphone
and they're all putting their hands all
over the same podium and you know every
there's been a lot of exposure obviously
they've all interacted with a lot of
people as you have did that surprise you
in terms of sending the right message to
the rest of the country in terms of
social distancing and how we should how
we should behave well the good news is
that the president has pretty regular
hygiene that he maintains regarding the
use of hand sanitizer and wipes he does
that he did that regularly before and so
I think that there's a certain
resilience with the president and those
around him but obviously we were all
anxious to get ball senarios test
results back because the president had
walked ball Cynara all over mar-a-lago
this last weekend where I was where a
number of other people were and so we
were hopeful that the right information
is out that that was a negative result
because that so far no community spread
at mar-a-lago at that event this last
weekend and we want to make sure it
stays that way but all of my friends are
at that party still healthy asymptomatic
and that's great news well that's good
just a quick question for you because I
read a report that said that you took
paid sick leave from Congress when you
were on your quarantine is that true and
if so they want to know why you voted
against that in Florida first of all I
never vote I never voted against paid
sick leave I voted to preempt paid sick
leave to the states so we didn't have 67
versions I have taken no paid sick leave
each and every day I've been home I've
been working with the governor our state
emergency response directors and
administration officials to ensure that
my constituents are cared for okay we
wanted to give you an opportunity to
respond to that criticism Matt Gaetz
congressman thank you